uh so it's hot as [ __ ] it's 108 degrees
and i'm not joking it's 108 degrees and
people in arizona right now are like so
who gives a [ __ ] and people in baghdad
right now are like so well does it
matter but i'm telling you right now
it's too hot
for los angeles and how do i know
how do i know it's too hot for los
angeles because dude breaking news
i killed a [ __ ] scorpion in my
doorway the other day
a scorpion
a scorpion
a scorpion but it's okay it was a small
one but then i googled it those are the
more poisonous ones why because they
need to rely on poison not their pincers
a scorpion
filled with poison at my door like it's
a jehovah's witness
at my door like it's a hare krishna at
my door like it's a mormon missionary
at my door like it's selling me girl
scout cookies but it doesn't have all
that it doesn't have a white button down
with short sleeves and a tie it doesn't
have that orange [ __ ] robe that they
wear it doesn't have any of that it just
has a [ __ ] tail ready to attack
dude a scorpion now i've been in los
angeles for 23 years that's a long time
okay 23 [ __ ] years
some people die before that
some people die before they're 23. i've
lived in los angeles a lifetime that's
what i'm telling you dude i've seen a
scorpion
one time and it was when i was just
watching by mistake scorpion king it's
the worst movie of all time but i've
never seen a scorpion except for on
youtube or when i'm in arizona i've seen
scorpions okay but there was a scorpion
in los angeles california
and i saw it and it was just chilling at
my doorway i got home it was late at
night
they come out at night
because that's when you know it gets hot
dude i want it indoors man and this even
the scorpion was like really nighttime
come on get the [ __ ] out of here we're
going in
dude it was ridiculous
and i was scared i was scared of [ __ ] to
it
but guess what i did
i overcame it
now whereas if it wasn't a spider or a
scorpion would i have killed it no if it
was an ant even if it was a big ant
i would have probably shoot it away i
would have probably kicked it right even
if it was a b i probably would have
flicked it like there was a b on
calvin's floaty the other day and
kristen says there's a bee on it you
might want to do something about it now
i wasn't worried because calvin's been
stung before and we know he's not
allergic so we're past that [ __ ] he's
two and a half i took the b i lined it
up ping flicked it out it hit the side
it was on the ground for a little bit
thought maybe i killed it and then it
just kind of walked away right
i think i probably
ended up flying i didn't kill it okay
that's my point i'm very good with
nature and i'm nice with nature okay i
don't [ __ ] break off branches and i
try not to kill bees unless they're
around write somebody that like if i
didn't know calvin was allergic
or not and b was around i would kill the
bee right
but a scorpion dude
so i looked at it and i [ __ ] stomped
it and i dragged it all in the house
when you dr when you man it was like it
was like i shot somebody
there was so much mess
it was like
and and it was a mess and then there was
like uh its body was still there like
scraped
it was like a [ __ ] i needed to take
cut like little [ __ ] spokes and
little caution tape for crime scene and
put the outline of the scorpion with the
[ __ ] white little white tape with the
little tail scooped up you know
but dude it was uh it was a menace man
it was at my door knocking and then i
[ __ ] killed it
and i walk up and one of my friends was
over with kristen and i say hey
i just killed a scorpion and she says
really and i say yeah
and then i go to kristin and i say i
just killed a scorpion and she said
really and i and i said yeah she said
where was i told her where it was we saw
the body dude it was just like this this
was the scorpion was like this
so anyway i googled it and i was like
okay
it wasn't a purple you ever see a big
purple if i saw a big purple one forget
it dude forget it
first the spider's in seattle and now
this the scorpions big scorpions they
have armor and [ __ ] they look like they
belong in game of thrones
and uh
and so i uh
i killed it and then i googled it and it
said you'll never see multiple scorpions
together like they're lone wolves and
i'm just like [ __ ] yeah dude maybe i'm
like a scorpion dude because that's kind
of how i am right i'm the scorpion
you know i don't really like to [ __ ]
with people because i don't trust them
scorpions you know what scorpions are
like tupac they're the tupac of of the
arachnids they're like yeah but trust no
one that's what a scorpion's like and
that's what i'm like you see a little
scorpion with the two little pinchers
and a [ __ ] backwards bandana tied
like aunt jemima but it's tupac with a
[ __ ] chain and a cross and a thing
that says 50 scorpions on his chest
with a z
that's me dude i'm the lone scorpion
i don't [ __ ] with nobody dude but i
killed him it was either me or my
[ __ ] son getting
sniped and hurt you know
[ __ ] scared to see a scorpion for the
first time ever people think i'm lying
dude i'm like dude
so anyway i killed a scorpion i'm
[ __ ] awesome if it was one of those
blue ones i would have got a [ __ ]
shield
god i don't like doing that
i don't like uh doing any of that uh
killing [ __ ] it makes me feel bad a
little bit i used to i used to think it
was clever when i was a kid people would
be like i'd be like ask me if i'm a
killer and they'd be like are you a
killer and i'd be like yeah and they
like you never killed anyone i'd be like
kill dance and then i would [ __ ] walk
away like like that's so something a
nine-year-old would do that would sing
with that thing that would think he's
badass
[Music]
crazy
[Music]